the world of assassination is on the
brink because of one man
as you take on the role of agent 47 his
deadly abilities tools and instincts are
at your fingertips
you get to travel the world and kill
interesting people
and with complete freedom of approach
making the how the when
and the where all up to you
47 can get in anywhere sometimes with
the aid of a stolen access card
a glean key code hacking the lock with
his new camera
or just using good old-fashioned brute
force
and sometimes all you need is an
invitation
you can blend in anywhere disguises
offer you access to corresponding areas
but be careful around enforcers they
will call your disguise if they get a
good look
47's arsenal has never been sharper
from the classics to the state of the
art
of course almost everything is a weapon
in 47's hands
but a creative assassin need never touch
a weapon
surrounding you is a living breathing
world of opportunity
action reaction cause and effect
from unfortunate accidents the careful
exploitation of a bad habit
you can trick someone else into doing
the dirty work or you could simply
book a meeting with your target
[Music]
but it's no walk in the park you must
adapt as circumstances change
your targets are some of the best
protected people in the world
some of them so elusive they are only
exposed for a limited time
unlock new tools and weapons in our
mastery tracks
refine your approach as you advance
across 20 mastery tiers per level
with new starting locations new ica gear
exotic distractions and stashed weapons
receive ratings based on your distinct
play style and skill level
and keep challenging yourself with a
slew of inventive escalations
and complications
[Music]
master the art of assassination and
nothing
can stop you
[Music]
you